Hi.
In this problem, we're going to
use the set of probability
axioms to derive the probability
of the difference
of two events.
Now, before we get started,
there's one thing you might
notice that, the equation
we're trying to prove is
actually quite complicated.
And I don't like it either, so
the first thing we're going to
do will be to find a simpler
notation for the events that
we're interested in.
So we start with two events, A
and B, and there might be some
intersection between
the two events.
We'll label the set of points
or samples in A that are not
in B, as a set C. So C will be
A intersection B complement.
Similarly, for all points that
are in B but not in A, this
area, we'll call it D.
And D will be the set A
complement intersection B. And
finally, for points that are in
the intersection of A and
B, we'll call it E. So E is A
intersection B. And for the
rest of our problem, we're going
to be using the notation
C, D, and E instead of
whatever's down below.
If we use this notation, we can
rewrite our objective as
the following.
We want to show that the
probability of C union D is
equal to the probability
of the event A plus the
probability of B minus twice the
probability of E. And that
will be our goal for
the problem.
Now, let's take a minute to
review what the axioms are,
what the probability
axioms are.
The first one says
non-negativity.
We take any event A, then
the probability of A
must be at least 0.
The second normalization says
the probability of the entire
space, the entire sample space
omega, must be equal to 1.
And finally, the additivity
axiom, which will be the axiom
that we're going to use for this
problem says, if there
are two events, A and B
that are disjoint--
which means they don't have
anything in common, therefore.
the intersection is
the empty set.
Then the probability of their
union will be equal to the
probably A plus the probability
of B. For the rest
of the problem, I will refer
to this axiom as add.
So whenever we invoke this
axiom, I'll write
"add" on the board.
Let's get started.
First, we'll invoke the
additivity axioms to argue
that the probability of C union
D is simply the sum of
probability of C plus
probability of
D. Why is this true?
We can apply this axiom, because
the set C here and the
set D here, they're completely
disjoint from each other.
And in a similar way, we'll
also notice the following.
We see that A is equal to the
union of the set C and E.
And also, C and E, they're
disjoint with each other,
because C and E by definition
don't share any points.
And therefore, we have probably
A is equal to
probability of C plus the
probability of E. Now, in a
similar way, the probability of
event B can also be written
as a probability of D plus the
probability of E, because
event B is the union
of D and E.
And D and E are disjoint
from each other.
So we again invoke the
additivity axiom.
Now, this should be enough
to prove our final claim.
We have the probability of C
union D. By the very first
line, we see this is simply
probability of C plus the
probability of D.
Now, I'm going to insert two
terms here to make the
connection with a second part of
the equation more obvious.
That is, I will write
probability C plus probability
E plus probability D plus
probability of E. Now, I've
just added two terms here--
probability E. So to make the
equality valid or subtract it
out two times, the
probability of E.
Hence this equality is valid.
So if we look at this equation,
we see that there
are two parts here that
we've already seen
before right here.
The very first parenthesis is
equal to the probability of A.
And the value of the second
parenthesis is equal to the
probability of B. We just
derived these here.
And finally, we have the minus
2 probability of E. This line
plus this line gives us
the final equation.
And that will be the answer
for the problem.